la parole est à monsieur pierre charon
merci monsieur le président je demande
la parole pour un rappel au règlement
dans la nuit du 13 au 14 mai de graves
incidents ont entaché la fête que paris
attendait depuis 19 ans grâce à la
victoire du psg
ces débordements ultra violents n'ont
pas su être anticipé ni même gérer alors
qu'une mise à sac des champs elysées
avaient déjà eu lieu la veille
cette gestion calamiteuse des violences
qui ont déferlé sur la capitale n'est
malheureusement pas sans rappeler
l'incompétence dont avait déjà fait
preuve le préfet de police bernard
boucault à l'occasion d'une
manifestation familiale et non violente
contre le mariage pour tous certains
élus socialistes ont osé parler de
récupération
devant les réactions d'élus parisiens je
les invite à les expliquer leur vision
des choses aux touristes dont l'autocar
a été pris d'assaut comme une diligence
je les invite à l'expliquer aux
commerçants qui ont été attaqués pillés
menacé et dont les magasins ont été
saccagés qu'il ne faut pas en faire une
histoire la presse internationale
regarde interloquée
le spectacle de la violence qui déferle
sur paris je demande donc au ministre de
l'intérieur manuel valls de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent pour que les
futures manifestations notamment celle
du 26 mai soit gérée par un préfet de
police professionnelle et pas en
préretraite
soucieux du respect du droit de
manifester et de la sécurité des
parisiens merci mon cher collecte acté
données de votre déclaration